in dirt a lot of difficult times
fighting hard we've been standing by him
it's a powerful message by the
tragically hip that has sent shockwaves
across the country and asking today that
lead singer gourd Downey is suffering
from terminal brain cancer
it's my difficult duty today to tell you
that for Downey's brain tumor is
incurable the 52 year old rock legend
received the diagnosis back in December
when he was rushed to the hospital after
a seizure gourd was given radiation
treatment for six weeks this consists of
30 treatments daily from Monday to
Friday for six weeks combined with
chemotherapy medication and after an MRI
scan last week and the amount of tumor
that we see residual has clearly shrunk
and he's doing very well
whispers of course health started last
Thursday when he was not at Queen's
University to accept an honorary degree
with the rest of the band and while
their latest releases in a world
possessed by the human mind and tiredest
had a lot of symbolism it was actually
an odd coincidence it's crazy the record
was made before this happened to single
all the things that have happened but
was that was not intentional no but in
true iconic rock star fashion gourd will
not let cancer bring them down the band
will hit the road and tour this summer
this feels like the right thing to do
now for gourd and for all of us what we
in the hip receive each time we play
together is a connection with each other
with music and it's magic and during the
shows a special connection with all of
you our incredible fans we will have
medical contingencies available for any
unexpected medical emergencies or
problems that come up
I don't anticipate that there will be
any though he's doing very well since
forming in 1984 hit fence had been with
the band
through it all nine number one albums in
Canada 14 Juno Awards inducted into the
Canadian Music Hall of Fame and in 2008
the band received the Governor General
National Art Center award it's just not
something you ever really imagined your
brain doesn't really have the capability
of processing it and of course there are
hundreds of songs we'll never forget by
one of Canada's greatest songwriters
ages
today prime minister justin trudeau
tweeted gore Downey is a true original
who's been writing Canada's soundtrack
for more than 30 years
hashtag courage while bare naked lady
said Gore Downey is a hero and friend of
mine I hate that he has brain cancer and
Will Arnett tweeted thoughts are with
Gore Downey and his family and friends